vai via via no marco del demonio
allora fermi tutti non mi sede settare
l'audio che ti ammazzo ti spacco quello
non c'entra niente questo so io allora
ragazzi vi spiego ciao questa anatra mi
accompagnerà nel gioco di oggi perché
che cosa ho deciso ovviamente per
complicarmi la vita io che cosa ho
deciso di farlo decide di fare una cosa
molto simpatica di giocare al rocket
league come state vedendo con l'anatra
che mi dà fastidio
in realtà ok quindi voglio vedere se
riesco a vincere una partita competiti
[Applauso]
competitiva di rocket league mentre no
no ragazzi stiamo già perdendo 1 0 non
farmi questo ti prego no raga non si può
vincere impossibile
io non posso vincere questa partita a
parte che mi laga anche un pelino perché
sono schermo
non è schermo intero alla finestra senza
bordi sono l'agente del caos si lo
vedono tra l'altro la regola è che non
posso togliere niente che la papera vi
mette quindi in questo momento io solo
questo che va ancora bene quindi se non
vinco la prima partita perché forse ne
farò due se non vinco la prima partita
veramente non vincere niente perché
immagino che la seconda sia già piena di
roba quindi già stiamo perdendo 2 a 0 e
questa è l'unica partita che
teoricamente potrei vincere quindi
perfetto un'altra cosa che veramente mi
debilita il fatto che va da un
pochettino non a scatti ma non è
completamente fluido con le mani era
stato dovuto scattare un mio compagno
sbaglio complimenti
no zia non hai capito basta lo vedo
niente c'è già un miracolo se mitico
cosa al centro perso che avevano vedo
niente non vedo neanche 2 vado male
vizia già così è un casino da ragazzino
l'allentamento è veramente orribile non
puoi giocare a rocket rigo con una
papera che ti butta in mezzo alla roba è
fattibile che forse ho segnato io 9
segna più bassa che la metti dentro ma
quanto sei stupido ma che problemi hai
dai che tu sei tu giochi con la papera
di la verità ma porco demonio porta
vuota che scarso maledizione alla vita
porta vuota che scarso poi è che sempre
a 20 ancora tutto recuperabile ancora
più giù duro vota per abbandonare cece
votiamo per abbandonare
grazie di essere dalla parte della
papera mio compagno stupido lui a questo
maledizione ha potuto pure cousseau pure
in cui pure il cursore porto demonio mi
serve a testa di culo a rai via alla
siamo contro annino potuto è una papera
ovviamente mio compagno impiccione
perché rimaniamo sempre lì mi sembra
ovvio tira compagno piccione fa vedere
che se in grado già la prima l'abbiamo
persa almeno la seconda qualcuno può
giocare dalla mia parte che o il
compagno contro la papera che mi dà
fastidio
qualcuno che gioca ok che se ifrs e il
cugino nella bara d'ufficio né però
almeno almeno un po dalla mia parte devi
stare
porca vacca questa partita già un po
meglio è almeno vedo in partenza grazie
testa di culo mancava solo questo
bravissimo in un compagno le prigioni le
prigioni che grande bravo
finalmente dopo un paio che gioca con me
pazzesco bravi tanto ha fatto le robe
pazzesche bravissimo le briciole
l'anatra bravo poi toni alti dal mezzo
ci sono un sacco di punti dove ti
permette grazie ma dai cosa ma preso
l'apparato la papera palo che sfiga
siamo 26 partite madonna sia io prima
che io adesso iniziano con ragazzi joe è
nel the past maurizio proprio lui il che
non diventi un vizio
niente avrei pestato una merda comunque
ragazzi ottimo perchè fino adesso sta
andando bene due a zero per noi
considerando anche la papera è un signor
risultato sono comunque contro dei
platino tre anni almeno quello e non
sono una papera anche il fatto che ciò
dei cali di frame considerevoli perché
la papera ragazzi un programma pesante
la legge per il mio computer è comunque
sempre buco una papera quindi
renderizzare una papera ti permette di
avere un calo di frame eccessivo tipo
questo che vedete fa niente cos'è quella
roba una jeep di a diana 3 parco demonio
non è il momento non ve non capisco
paolo palomba di piana tra e paro aiuto
lo toglierla toglie madonna no la
mancata di impararla zio bravissimo ero
sbagliato ho sbagliato scusami scusa non
volevo farlo però la beta ogni la
madonna che scarso ho capito che ho
sbagliato ma toglie la metterà lato cioè
che scarso 20 la via madonna no no per
favore non è un momento meno male che la
sovrapposta puro di prima ha detto wen
chin als ong mm il mio dio non mi
mettere in m in questo momento non è il
momento
porco del demonio morto di neve non è il
momento di mettermi dei meme ti prego
sto avendo problemi che non guardare la
palla non va mi distrae non guardare la
palla guarda fai altro vivi la tua vita
fai schifo
oddio dove il mio compagno dov'è il mio
compagno tocca palla fa qualcosa 26 non
c'è
il gioco io certo sono io qua basta
contro la palla fa qualcosa dov'era ma
dio madonna quello che ha pestato e
parte è stato il fallo bravo bravo in
bassa che imbratti il tuo nord non
citata diventare 3 a 2 sul finale porco
demonio porco demonio porco porco
demonio vincevamo 2 a 0 3 a 2
maledizione ti sei alleato con la papera
di la verità teatro fastidio che stavi
per vincere contro il tuo cugino e
allora niente a abbiamo perso abbiamo
perso in una maniera pazzesca
smettila ma per ma perché ma perché
proprio è quello e cosa bus bus
simulator gomes chiave untitled goodgame
quello che ho già fatto la papera
maledizione è uno screen del gioco
grazie molto bello gentile sono già due
partite che perdono veramente non so
come ringraziarti adesso andiamo per la
terza è l'ultima la porta e l'altra
perché giocano tutti con la papera i
miei compagni milano contro bravo
dai dai mettila dentro è facile adesso
faccio io ok ma forse madonna
finché non mette niente a paper agiate 1
dai dai dai forza camon bravo che hai
tolto
comunque no veramente c'è un like è
allucinante
mio dio non mettere blocco note va
ancora bene difficile digitare con le
zampe lo so lo vedo mai zap fatti valere
noi due controllate l'anatra la papera
quello che vuoi
non so la differenza a glielo corsa thai
88 va dai barca vacca niente non è
riuscita a togliere grazie delle buone
ma bellissimo cavolo che spiega prova
tirare se ci sei bravo lo zio e del 2 a
1 con la papera perché sia un grande
traguardo questo secondo me neanche i
campioni rocket league riesco a giocare
con non me ne frega se sei un agente del
caos che fastidio mi dai fastidio per
cortesia
smettila arco demonio aiuto
è successo qua e non 80 non posso
metterla in mezzo ai tu e tu faccio io
lo faccio io
look e gol nola toglie la torre di
antonio invece cosa maurizio proprio lui
dai dai che se continuiamo così ce la
facciamo dai zio forza non mi spostare
quello meno male che non mi ha messo non
è in mezzo legale perché ancora credo
che ci sia possibilità che rispondi roba
in mezzo perché se fa quello o presso
cioè nel senso non vedo niente veramente
nulla nulla cosmico cio togliti pezzente
ho fatto con la macchina quello che
vorrei fare una papera poi salta salta
salta il buon lavoro
grazie ci sto provando cosa e sfotte la
mancata in volo io non posso andare
sulla mischia va al camp nou è paolo
però prendo demonio tira fa qualcosa
dove sei ma prendiamo dove vedere non
era né in attacco in difesa
[Musica]
no non abbiamo preso che non ho più
turbo manca un minuto ti puoi togliere
dal centro che non vedo non vedo
se manca è il momento cruciale della
partita questo perché siamo messi bene e
dove esiste ancora un attimo tipo e
toglierli nel momento sbagliato per
stare nel centro dello schermo grazie
perfetto bella come te lo me come glielo
messa all avversario bravo bravissimo ti
avviati è però ci prova ci trascina li
proci non lo fa
beh ho sbagliato de sisti cali di
framerate tocca la tocca la tocca labbra
benissimo e adesso guarda adesso
promette adesso via momento la
difficoltà io guarda me lo schiaffo io e
mezzo non vedo niente
facciamo questi quest ultimo minuto con
la cosa nel mezzo perfetta per tutto
questo il competitivo ha mai abbandonato
ho vinto ho vinto io perfetto migliore
della partita migliore la partita con la
papera con le robe in mezzo e con il
calo di framerate ragazzi ottimo spero
che vide vi sia piaciuto questo era o
non lo so neanche spiegare però volevo
farlo può e non ne ha neanche così
andata male pensavo peggio complimenti
alla partita mi sono anche molto
divertito complimenti alla papera che ha
sempre un sacco di cose da dire vedo
iscritte le querelle schiacciatela
campale li na prima della giornata i
suoi di video e noi come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vi do bella
ragazzi
[Musica]